Welcome to this
episode of UXD, where
I will talk about how to
create compelling user
experiences that
will effectively
engage your users
by understanding how
visual attention and
memory actually work.
This first episode of
this two-part series
is all about understanding
visual attention.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
I'll explain how
human attention works
and how we can respect the
constraints around attention
to deliver a really
good user experience.
And if we violate
these constraints,
there's a good chance
that a bad experience
will be delivered to users
of your applications.
Now, we've all experienced
moments of delight.
And I'll explain why some
of these moments happen
and how it's not random
and totally repeatable
using real-world examples.
Now as humans, we're just
actually a bag of sensors.
We perceive our world
with these sensors.
A key part of delivering
a good user experience
is not violating
constraints around
how we perceive our world.
It's all about leveraging
how our sensors actually work
and delivering
feedback to them that
will match our expectations
and even delight us
by exceeding our expectations.
So let's talk about
visual attention,
since sight is one
of the main senses
that we use to perceive
our environment.
Now as humans, we can
only process small chunks
of visual information
that we take in.
This is something that
we do so that we are not
overwhelmed constantly
by the information that
is being streamed into
our visual sensors
from our environment.
Now through evolution,
we've gotten
really good at
selectively tuning out
things that are not
important to our survival
in the present moment.
And as a consequence of getting
really good at tuning things
out, we have something called
selective attention, which
is if we focus on
one area, we tend
to miss others in this process.
Now, there's a great YouTube
video that showcases this.
And I encourage you
watch this video.
The QR code for the video
is on the screen below.
Now, I won't ruin it for you if
you've not watched it already.
But it will actually have
you go through an exercise
where you'll see how easy it
is for us to ignore everything
around us when we get
focused on something
that's right in front of us.
Another example is if you're
currently really involved
composing an email in Gmail
on your Android phone,
you might easily miss
system notifications.
Now, the unique challenge in
creating a compelling user
experience is
designing for something
called attentional capture.
So we just tune out
things that are not
relevant to our
currently-executing task.
This is a survival mechanism.
And we've evolved
to do this in order
to be able to process things
in our everyday blindness.
Another way to say this
is change blindness.
That's what it's called--
change blindness.
And we can use this to deliver
compelling user experiences.
For example, let's say you've
built a news reader application
that has an article
reading view that
shows the number
of unread articles
that are available on
the top right-hand corner
of the screen.
And let's say it uses most of
the surface area of the screen
to show the full content
of whatever article
that your user is
currently reading.
Now let's say a user is using
the app to read an article
and is immersed in the content.
If the unread count changes
on the top right-hand corner
of the screen, they're
probably not going
to notice that
change, which signals
to them that new articles are
now available for them to read.
So if your goal is to update
this unread count silently
without getting the
user's attention,
then you can just leave
things the way they are.
And this will, essentially,
deemphasize that part
of the user interface
to the user.
Now, there's a valid
use case for this,
since not every
single change really
deserves your user's attention.
So depending on what
your desired outcome is,
you can leverage this, change
blindness to your benefit.
Now, if your goal is to grab the
user's attention with the fact
that the unread
count has changed,
then you might consider
using an animation
to draw their attention to it.
Object animations draw
the user's attention
to the change in
your user interface.
And depending on how
you do the animation,
it suggests what type
of change has actually
occurred to that object.
Another way to grab
a user's attention
is to use something called
a flicker effect, which just
means that people sense
differences in what they see
if these changes happen
more rapidly than not.
So if you want your
users to become aware
of a specific
change in an object,
you might consider showing
the old state and then
the new state, but
do this quickly.
And the quicker you
show the change,
it's perceived as
a flicker, and that
will capture their
attention more.
So we've been talking about
selective attention, which
gives us insight into how we've
become really good at ignoring
things around us when we
get focused on something.
So now let's switch gears and
talk about divided attention.
So it puts a really
high cognitive load
on a user to split their
selective attention
between different items
or areas simultaneously.
So multitasking is, cognitively,
a very expensive thing
to do for any user.
People don't actually multitask.
People just perform
really expensive context
switching between single tasks.
So it's really important
to design for this reality.
There's a great NPR
article on research
done about how people
actually multitask.
And I encourage you to read it.
The QR code for this article
is on the screen below.
And it's called, "Think
You're Multitasking?
Think Again."
You might have experienced
a scenario like this before.
Let's say you're
editing a Google Doc,
and people are pinging you
at the same time on Hangouts.
It's probably distracted
you from the task
you were performing
editing your Doc.
And having to respond to
these IMs and work on the Doc
at the same time, you
incur a high cognitive cost
for doing each of these
relatively simple tasks,
because of the expensive
context switch that
occurs when you shift
your attention from one
to the other.
Here's another example.
Let's say you're busy coding up
something and you get emails.
If you read these
emails, you will
tend to lose your
coding-related train of thought.
So emails can be very
distracting for this reason,
since they interrupt
the flow and cause
you to switch context.
So when you're in
the zone or the flow,
these interruptions
bring you out of it,
and these interruptions come
at a high cognitive cost.
And at the end of
the day, it ends up
costing more energy,
more cognitive energy,
to accomplish a task
when you're constantly
getting taken out of
the flow and having
to switch context
between different tasks.
Now on the flip
side, you might want
to divide a user's attention and
have them split it differently
between many different
items and areas.
And a great example of this
is an immersive video game.
So imagine you're
playing "Halo,"
and you're focused on all kinds
of bad guys in front of you.
And you also have
to take into account
all other kinds of key
performance indicators
in the periphery, like your
ammo, health, and shield,
while you're moving around
in an alien environment
and interacting with lots
of different objects.
So immersive video
games actually
train a user to have much
higher situational awareness.
This actually is a good
thing in real life.
So when you're walking on
a road or you're driving,
you want to be aware of
oncoming traffic, pedestrians,
and so on.
And you actually need to keep
track of multiple objects
at the same time.
So at the end of the day, design
for what your use case actually
is.
If you need users to be
immersed in the flow,
then design for
fewer interruptions.
If you want users to have
higher situational awareness--
like in an immersive
video game--
then go ahead and
divide their tension,
but understand that there's
a cost and a benefit
to doing each of these things.
Now, the unique
challenge we face
is that we have to
design compelling user
experiences that engage the
user given that they have
selective attention
and change blindness.
This is not easy,
but it can be done.
So coming back to
animations, this
is one of the main
reasons animations
are really important.
It's not just about
making something look
pretty or polished.
Transient changes-- which are
small movements, such as those
in animations
between objects-- are
more likely to capture
your user's attention.
For example, if you
change the color
of a button in your Android
app or a text field,
the user might not
really notice that.
But if you animate those
views, then the user
will probably see that change.
Now, one example is the
Hangouts app for Chrome.
Let's say that you're
chatting with your friend
and you've not received a
message from them in a while.
The Hangout app
window is going to be
minimized and out of the way.
However, as soon as you
get pinged by your friend,
the app will start to
vie for your attention
by doing a subtle animation
and popping up partially to let
you know the chat
window is active.
And it also changes colors and
pulses to get your attention.
This is very subtle,
but it's a great way
to get your attention without
actually distracting you
from whatever task you
might have been doing.
So another example of this
is Google+ notifications
in Android.
When you're in Google+
application in Android and you
get a notification, it just
animates that bell icon,
the thing on the top right-hand
corner of the screen,
to let you know that there's
something that might need
your attention.
So this is something
that you pick up
in your peripheral
vision, which is
taking advantage of
change blindness.
It also puts the
number of notifications
that are being stacked
up on the bell.
So if you're in the
middle of doing something
else at the time and you're
using selective attention,
you can simply ignore this.
However, you don't actually
lose these notifications,
because they're
getting queued up.
And you come back to
them later at any time.
Also if you have
come back to them
and you view the
notifications and you
want to go back to them,
they're actually not lost.
You can go back and look at
the history of notifications.
So all these things
take advantage
of change blindness and
selective attention.
And rather than
work against them,
it works with them to deliver
a really good user experience.
So that's all the
time we have today.
If you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a great place where we
can continue this discussion.
And you can meet others who
are just as passionate about UX
as you are.
Thanks for watching and goodbye.